if you create one good film and you and
you were one of the fortunate few people
that did the things that that all
filmmaker should do but very few do
which is to come up with a marketing
strategy no your hook no at least
roughly who your target audience is and
and actually figure out a way in your
marketing budget to have some money to
tell least grease grease the gears a
little bit to get things moving is there
a reason for people to come back and
spend more time with you later or see
your next work I think that varies and
once again there's not I wish there was
like a like one answer fits all kind of
thing but there isn't there's some
filmmakers out there like the like the
polish brothers for example that that
have they did that great love story what
was I called four levers only four
lovers on iconic and then they came up
with the making of video and the making
up videos is currently on chill and I
have to say that's very successful
successful in the sense I don't know
what their numbers are but I can tell
you that there's people on there that
are tweeting about it that are sharing
it that are communicating the value of
this making making of movie right and
these are people that you think like
they must love that content and that
filmed so much on an emotional level
that they they just need more and that's
really interesting to me and I think it
answers your question because in that
scenario here's here's the love story
the actual movie here's the making of
the love story and this is like well
it's not the movie but at least it gets
me back because before hungry I think
for that emotional connection they want
that thing so that's what they're coming
back for is it going to work on every
movie I don't know I mean I certainly
you know in the in the case of Star Wars
which is way out of the context of
independent filmmaking okay one can
argue that first one was independence I
don't want to get into that but the
point is for years I waited for the next
Star Wars movies to come out I wanted
that I wanted that emotional connection
I wanted to go back to that story and I
can probably think of other movies like
back to the future did it for me well if
you remember the first Back to the
Future came out and then he had to wait
several it felt like a decade it was I
think two years if you look
maybe but that felt so long and I was a
kid then and you know I'm coming up with
these examples but gosh I really loved
those stories and I wanted to see more
so if there were serialized content
related to that I would definitely go
back and take a look at it and you know
I'm sure I'm not alone in that I know
I'm not
you